hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast unique molecular indices Umi
and their application and detecting
novel gene fusion and gene expression
and genetic variation I am Robert
Castellanos of lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Teijin whether your passion
for answers takes you to a laboratory
bench or a hospital bedside the pursuit
often begins with the blood or tissue
sample the deepest mysteries of disease
and other biological processes the
answers you seek are encoded in the
building blocks of life DNA if the work
of learning what these molecules can
tell you is quite a journey and we
encourage and understand the challenges
associated with this quest our
commitment to enable you to quickly and
reliably reach your goal of useful
actionable insights to this end kaijin
offers you innovative solutions cover
every single set along this journey not
just technologies but bridges from
sample to insight sample to insight
means kaijin offers you the industry's
most reliable sample technologies
because their samples matter to your
success our top quality of saves and
panels enable you to accurately analyze
and identify diseases and genetic
variations our bioinformatics software
and curated knowledgebase transform your
raw data into relevant actionable
findings and our automated solutions
provide you seamless cost-effective
workflows sample to insight the insights
you gain may lead to one small step or
one giant leap forward for science and
health care partnering with kaijin your
work can make a difference for more
information please visit chi cheng com
there's a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge a slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems
there's a green Q&A button lower left
this is an educational webinar and best
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C button located in the top
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits it is my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker dr. Samuel rune dr.
sandy really received his PhD in 2002
from Tulane University pursued
postdoctoral research at Johns Hopkins
University and the National Cancer
Institute and Frederick trained as a
molecular biologist dr. really started
working in the industry in 2007 and has
worked on different things detection
technologies for gene expression and
nucleic acid analysis torrent linking as
a global product manager at collagen
specializing in qpcr and NGS best based
detection of both protein and non-coding
rnas a pathway and disease I would now
like to turn it over to dr. Rudy for his
presentation
thank you very much Bobby thank you very
much for everybody who's here in
attendance for today's webinar we're
going to focus on moving in a direction
of targeted sequencing and one of the
things that we've done at collagen is to
look at targeted sequencing over the
last couple of years and really look at
trying to improve the clarity on what
you're actually sequencing and we've
also gone through and incorporated some
what we
are very nice technical improvements in
traditional sequencing workflows that
allows us to sequence very gc-rich
regions where we couldn't do this before
with amplicon based sequencing it allows
us now to go through and have a method
to detect fusion genes whether we know
partners or not and now we can apply
this to gene expression and micro RNA
profiling in this picture here you'll
see these really nice molecular barcodes
or molecular tags and during today's
presentation I'm going to refer to these
as unique molecular indexes and the way
to really think about these is that when
we go through and do any sort of
sequencing typically the end points of
our analysis are reads and we take the
reads and we map these back to our
reference genome and this allows us to
identify what's there and then we can
look at the number of reads as a
surrogate for the expression level or at
the level of the targets that we were
looking at if you've ever gone through
and looked at this and done a lot of
this in either low complex libraries or
from SFP samples which we deal a lot
with in cancer research you know that
there is a possibility to have
amplification bias or library bias which
can really corrupt your final numbers in
addition your sequencing machines do a
very good job at sequencing however
there can be errors that are
incorporated during the sequencing
process and so the idea behind unique
molecular indexes or going through and
adding these barcodes to all of our
different analytes we're looking at is
that as we go through and we build our
libraries were able to go through and
tag every capture event that goes on and
when we go through you'll see that when
we do this for gene expression now we
can take an average desktop sequencing
machine and make it very quantitative we
can now spit out gene expression numbers
we can now go through and quantitate
micro RNA we can go through and look at
copy number variation and then also go
through and look at all the great things
the sequencing machine does it does
great things with sequences and now we
can start to interpret the sequences
with the unique molecular indexes
allowing us to go through and have
clarity and what we're looking at so I
need to remind everybody that during
today's webinar the products that are
shown
they're intended for molecular biology
applications and these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of disease and either humans
or your pets at home for up to the date
licensing information and product
specific disclaimers please feel free to
go through and look in the kaiju kit
handbook user manuals which are
available on courage and calm can be
requested through a distributor or
through kaijin technical services so one
of the big important fields that I've
often looked at and worked in is tumor
heterogeneity and tumeric community has
a lot of problems as far as being able
to go through and identify what is
actually going on in that tumor the
tumors are notoriously a mixed
population of cells there could be
infiltrating cells and depending on
where you're looking within the tumor
whether it's the middle part the outside
part even the surrounding tissue you can
have a different molecular signature
when we're going through we're looking
at tumor heterogeneity or any tumors in
general samples are often limiting and
being able to detect the analytes that
you're looking at from FFPE is a
necessity of most research research
cancer research programs as well as
anything that's going through and trying
to develop out how the molecular
mechanism or the PD or what's going on
in that particular sample the idea
behind looking at tumor heterogeneity
and being able to identify different
types of analytes is that tumor
heterogeneity leads to highly variable
cancers and differential responses to
these particular types of tumors can be
guided by understanding what's going on
at the molecular level so on the left
hand side here we have this really nice
picture that kind of illustrates why we
want to be able to understand what the
tumor is how the tumor is working and to
be able to use this as a way to guide
future treatments so we have here a
situation where we have a population of
people and you can look at their
different legs as far as whether or not
they're going to respond to a particular
therapy and in this population of people
they all have colon cancer however their
colon cancers we know it are all
different they're at different potential
stages they could have a different
molecular signature a different driving
thing and they may respond to
different therapies and if we look at
this population of people that have
colon cancer and we give them this green
drug here then we're going to have some
patients that respond very well some
that have no effects and of course we
may have several people in this
population that have a very bad effect
to this and it's actually not the cancer
you
thank you very much to the audience for
a momentary aspect of technical
difficulties we'll be with you in just
one moment
although although
well
okay excellent good sorry about that I'm
actually dialed in to our webinar this
morning and I seem to have been
disconnected so but the wonders of
modern technology so as I was saying
here on the left-hand side here we have
our patients they all have colon cancer
they each have a different type of colon
cancer they may respond to a particular
therapy and we have some patients that
we give them the green pill that they
will respond well some that will have no
effect and some that will have a very
negative effect and they're not killed
because the cancer but because the
therapy we gave them by going through
and looking at the tumors that the
patient has we can go through and start
to look for biomarkers and really the
biomarkers that we want to look at could
be a gene expression profile the micro
RNAs that are there it could be
detecting particular fusion genes and
DNA variants or if we go through and we
have a way that we can detect all of
those we can go through and for each of
these different patients we can give
them the correct therapy that allows
them to go through and for everybody to
have a beneficial effect and so the idea
behind this is that if we're going
through and we're going to develop these
biomarkers out they need to be monitored
over time so before treatment during
treatment after treatment low frequency
events are important at high frequency
events so in these particular tumors
we're looking at tumors that may be a
very small fraction of that and
represent a very small fraction of the
mutational burden these could actually
be very important to monitor because as
we kill off the bulk mark amount of that
tumor these may escape and actually
become very aggressive and really the
challenge that we have when we're
dealing with tumor heterogeneity it's
not the fact that we can detect the
cancer but it's being able to go through
and detect low-frequency events and as
many of these events as possible
so we can go through and have an idea of
the particular type of tumor we're
dealing with and how to best treat this
so for going through and looking at this
this is really where targeted sequencing
can be brought to bear in targeted
sequencing we can go through and we can
isolate the particular nucleic
we want to look at and then go through
and identify whether there's a variance
there by doing DNA sequencing we can go
through there and we can identify fusion
genes look at gene expression signatures
look at micro RNA and if we know how to
do all of this together we can actually
go through and take a very educated
approach to what we're dealing with and
how to treat that targeted sequencing is
uniquely positioned to address these
problems because of the following
challenges that we have with tumor
heterogeneity we have low amounts of
sample input often we're dealing with
anything from a very few cells down to
maybe even a single cell targeted
sequencing is very robust on FFPE or
damaged samples in addition targeted
sequencing allows us to go through and
even access information that may not be
in the tumor but coming from the tumor
so in the processes of looking at liquid
biopsies we can go through and identify
mRNA of long non-coding RNA signatures
from exosomes micro rnas that may be
floating there and as well as any
circulating free DNA with targeted
sequencing this allows us to go through
and not send everything to a center that
has a high seat so we can actually go
through and start to use benchtop NGS
instruments things that don't have to
have 400 million reads but may only have
25 million reads because with targeted
sequencing we're going to go through and
we're going to focus on the actionable
parts in that particular therapy and
that particular tumor
in addition targeted sequencing has
highly simplified biomat file
informatics as well as a greatly
straightforward workflow so to go
through to take a tumor to go through
and isolate the material that we need to
use and go through identify what's going
on this can simply be done in a couple
of days so one of the focus on today is
clients targeted sequencing panels and
I'm going to look go through the
following four topics the first is going
through and talking about the principle
of using unique molecular indexes how do
these umi's allow us to go through and
take a typical sequencing machine and
make it very quantitative how does it
give us clarity on low frequency
variants I'll talk about using single
primer extension at vs. using PCR for
library construction if you've gone
through in the past
and done a lot of sequencing and use PCR
to make your libraries you know that
there's certain regions of the genome
you can't go through and amplify you
know that if you're going through and
doing gene expression this can get very
complicated because now you need two
regions and there may be secondary
structure or you may be you may need to
predict the region that you're looking
at and perfusion genes you would need to
know both partners the using single
primer extension we can actually get
around all those situations I'll go
through and I'll look at using it this
in an application example it's a drug
screening program that we've been
working on it's using the Ilyas and SPE
s to go through and to identify novel
compounds and try to understand the
molecular mechanism of action and then
I'll talk a little bit about applying
this for DNA very analysis and novel
fusion genes so when we're going through
and we're looking at identifying the
gene expression pattern of the
particular genes that we're looking at
in our samples this is a typical working
workflow that we may be using so here
we're going through and we have our gene
of interest so I'm gonna call it gene a
and we have it in both sample1 and
sample2 and then sample one we have four
copies of this versus one copy in sample
one so we have a four-fold increase in
the gene expression in sample one
person's sample two in the typical
workflow for doing either PCR or
sequencing we're going to take the RNA
make cDNA and we're going to preserve
the original ratio of this up four to
one at the cDNA level now when we go to
cDNA and we throw this on to our
sequencing machine if we're going
through and using and amplicon based
strategy or even with some of the
machines that we have we can also get
optical duplicates when we go through
and we look at the number of raw reads
we might have twelve reads versus six
reads and after normalization if we went
through we looked at the ratio not the
ratio it's two to one so we went from a
biologically important for full change
now down to a experimental to full
change and if this was an important gene
that was being regulated by a micro RNA
or part of your biomarker program you
might actually go through and miss this
gene as something that was important you
may go through
mischaracterized this particular sample
so the idea here is that we need to go
through and take our sequencing from a
read based approach to counting the
number of transcripts so here is the
scenario that we were just talking about
on the left hand side I started with a
particular sample I had 1 transcript
there and when I look at the reads on my
sequencing machine I'm going to get five
replicates of one transcript so I have
five reads here if we go through and we
count the number of reads we count this
as five on the right-hand side here I
have a totally different biological
situation I have five unique transcripts
I go through and I sequence this each
transcript got sequence one time but if
we count the number of reads I still get
five if I look at this there's
absolutely no difference to me on a read
to read based approach and I would say
that the samples I started with are
exactly identical however if we can go
through and add in a unique molecular
identifier here so on the left hand side
you can see we have the gray blooming on
the right hand side here we've
incorporated five different unique
molecular indexes so now we have five
different molecular tags when we go
through we use the reads as a way to map
it back and identify what we sequence
and then we just count the number of
molecular tags so on the left hand side
here we had actually saying we started
with one transcript we sequenced at five
times and now we have a countess as one
gene to start with and then on the right
hand side we go through we say that we
had five reads we counted each read one
time and we would count this as five
unique transcripts so here we can go
through and preserve the actual five to
one ratio that's there in the cells if
you start to apply this to gene
expression you can see it becomes
instantly quantitative for DNA we can
now call copy number variations and then
later on if we actually use the
sequencing information we can go back
and look at the variants that may be
there and know whether it's a true
variant versus a false negative so going
back and applying this to our gene
expression approach when we go through
and we put this into our workflow we
start with our gene expression within
ourselves we go through and we make
first strand cDNA and then when we go
through we make second string
see DNA we incorporate in our unique
will let your index here you see we've
gone through here and we've incorporated
in four different UMI's based on the
different arrows here versus one umi we
go through and we do our raw sequencing
we still have 12 reads versus 6 reads
but when we go through and we count the
number of unique will let your indexes
we still preserve the ratio of 4 to 1
and so the illuminates are actually
allowing us to go through and to remove
any library bias that we may incorporate
during library construction for
sequencing the way that we're doing this
for gene expression is by going through
and using a really fancy primer so in
order to go through and apply gene
expression and have a very simple
workflow we're using a gene specific
primer that's part of our single primer
extension and then we're adding back a
region behind this that has 12 random
bases which gives us about sixteen point
seven million unique molecular indexes
so in this primer here we have a gene
specific region to your favorite gene
and get extended off the right-hand side
here by the polymerase after it binds to
its cDNA target on the back end of this
we have our twelve random basis which
give us our sixteen point seven million
unique molecular indexes and then behind
this we have a universal region that we
can use in subsequent downstream PCR
reactions once we've going through and
done the single primer extension we've
incorporated and being equal like your
index and then from there we can do that
as much PCR as we want to build out the
library which leads to a very simplified
and quick workflow that can lead to
library construction in as little as a
day the second technical logical
improvement that we put into our
targeted sequencing has to do with how
we actually capture our stuff we use
single primer extension and single
primer extension is nothing other than
going through and having your target
having the primer as the event that's
going to be able to capture the
information and then what we do is we go
through and we just extend off of where
that primer has bound to the particular
target to look at
instead of going through and doing PCR
amplification we found that single
primer extension has a lot of
technological advances with the single
primer extension we only need to know
one region for primer design so this
allows us to go through and really
unlock the entire transcriptome genome
and any sort of fusion gene you want to
identify this also lowers the number of
total primers by at least half as
compared to doing PCR amplification this
allows us to have a lower cost and
allows for greater content during
multiplexing when you're going through
and doing PCR based capture then you
have to go through and worried whether
or not you have enough of the agents in
there how many primer pairs can I crowd
into that often when you put two primers
together you can get primer Diner
interactions and the libraries that you
build even though you're going through
and building a lot of library they
actually have a lot of stuff in there
that you actually don't want to sequence
with the finger primer extension we can
go through and we can adopt this to GC
rich regions hard to PCR regions and
basically sequence everything and the
reaction characteristics around a single
primer extension are very uniform so
this means to very uniform library
construction and uniform sequencing we
no longer see regions of the genome when
we're looking at that or transcriptome
which will out-compete other regions
during the sequencing run and what's
really nice about single primer
extension is this strategy works very
very well on FFPE fragmented RNA and
even very low quality samples we're not
going through and need two primers to
bind if our RNA or DNA is highly
fragmented we can adjust to this just by
moving the primers or coming up with an
alternative single primer tiling screen
the one disadvantage of this which I
don't know if you really consider this a
disadvantage with the improvement that
we get with the data is that we now
break up the steps of capture from one
step of PCR amplification into single
primer extension then we do a clean up
steps to remove unincorperated single
primers and then we go through and we do
PCR amplification to finish the capture
events so this does add one extra step
to library construction and maybe an
hour of total
worked so this is a application of going
through and how we're using the unique
molecular identifier some single primer
extension to identify novel gene
expression profiles this is a small
molecule screen that we're doing and
we're looking at this from a perspective
of a signal transduction application the
experiment that we're doing is to go
through here and to look at the gene
expression as a way to identify the
molecular mechanism of these novel
compounds that we're adding back to
ourselves the experiment starts by us
going through and starting with cells in
96-well plates we're going through and
we're treating them with a class of
novel compounds and then we're going
through and extracting the RNA so my
typical workflow for doing this is to go
through and to treat the cells probably
for about an hour and then when we
extract the RNA we're going to go
through and we're going to use this to
build a library to look at about 421
targets which covers about 16 canonical
pathways we're currently going through
and building these libraries from as
little as 10 nanograms of total RNA but
we can even push that down a little bit
more into the picogram range if
necessary the way that we go through and
we're building the libraries is going
through and pretty much following the
workflow that you see on your screen so
we're going through and we're extracting
the RNA after extracting the RNA we
treat it with a quick DNA s to remove
any residual genomic DNA and then we're
going through and doing C DNA synthesis
just like you would do if you were doing
this for PCR or any other type of
technique during cDNA synthesis we use
random primers and others ODT priming so
we don't necessarily need to have a poly
a on our target so if you're interested
in looking at long non-coding RNAs or if
we start with samples that the poly a is
either falling off or it's or if it's an
FFP sample we could still get adequate
amounts of cDNA made then we're going to
go through and do our first enzymatic
reaction which is that single primer
extension so we put all the primers that
we're going to use each primer is a
family of primers and we go through and
we do this enzymatic reaction and after
the single primer our capture that we've
gone through
and we've made double-stranded cDNA and
what stranded at cDNA now has the unique
molecular index that's specific for each
gene specific priming event from here we
go through and we're going to do a
reaction clean up using magnetized beads
they bind to the double-stranded DNA we
capture this with a magnet and then we
can go through and allude off the
product that we need for our next
reactions the next reaction we do is a
first stage PCR here we're using a gene
specific reverse primer and then a
universal primer on the other end that
binds to the region that we incorporated
with our single primer extension the
really nice thing about breaking up the
traditional PCR capture into a single
primer extension with a universal PCR
step is that the gene specific primers
never see each other
so this removes a lot of primer primer
interaction and this also allows us to
crowd even more content into our typical
library one more reaction clean up and
then we're going through and we're doing
inline sample indexing for sample
indexing we can just use a PC our
approach we incorporate in the adopter
that we're going to use for our
sequencing machine whether it's an
Illumina platform or a thermo Fisher
platform and then we're ready to go
through do one more reaction clean up
and then move on to library
quantification from start to finish this
is a typical six-hour protocol it takes
about an hour for each of the enzymatic
reactions to run so you can put your
reactions into a thermo cycle and walk
away from it and it takes about 30
minutes to do each of these bead cleanup
steps if you go through and you have a
robot in your lap or you can automate
this process you can get this whole six
hours down to about an hour of actual
hands-on time most of it will be setting
up and then go through moving the plates
or reloading the robots that you're
using for researchers who want to take
this and incorporate this into your
basic research labs all you really need
to do this is a pipette a magnet for the
bead cleanup and then you just need a
thermal cycler to do the enzymatic
reactions once we now have the kind of
the idea of using unique molecular
indexes to tag every single molecule
that we're going to sequence we
have a way to go through and build the
library now we need to put this in a
sequencing workflow which I call the
leave no scientist behind workflow it
starts by going through and isolating
the RNA that you're starting with so we
all know that hydrogen has a lot of RNA
isolation kits we can go through and if
we're interested in looking at micro RNA
mRNA long non-coding RNA and fusion
genes we can start with a near and easy
isolation kit this allows us to capture
all the RNA from 18 bases on up from a
typical Mir and easy we can go through
and just take an aliquot the RNA and
then go through and query the particular
analytes we're interested in if you're
starting with FFPE start with a kit that
says F F pan it we also have kids for
going through and extracting extracting
RNA from exosomes as well as other types
of analytes the decisions that you make
in this in this workflow are very very
limited all you have to really worry
about is the content that you're going
to use in your panel the panels that we
have are some are available on the shelf
some can be extended by you adding back
your own custom genes to that and then
you can also go through and build a
custom panel currently for our gene
expression platform we look at anywhere
from 12 to a thousand targets in a
particular library construction on
workflow for going through and building
your piano kit all the necessary tools
that you need are included in the kit so
it has the cdna reaction the kiya seed
bead cleanup as well as all of the
primers already pre Alec wanted into a
single tube when we go through we do our
library construction everything is a
single tube reaction no need to go
through and do PCR and pull it later on
once we've gone through and we've done
our panel our library construction
there's two other kits that we need in
order to complete our library we need an
index kit the index kit is the sample
index kit this is determined by the
sequencing machine you use so if using
alumina you use an Illumina index kit if
you using thermo Fisher use a thermal
Fisher index kit and then we have a
library quantification tip for
quantifying the amount of library that
we have we use a cyber green to PCR
assays that looks at incorporation of
the indexes we supply an absolute
her for that and you can go through no
the peak of moles of library go through
and normalize your library and then pull
everything together so you have equal
more concentrations of your library so
here you're going to go through and run
this on your sequencing instrument at
the end of today's presentation I'll
show you a table that has the different
number of samples that you can run you
can use anything from a benchtop
instrument like a mini seek of my seat
to a midsize like a next week to a
high-capacity instrument like one of the
high seats or any of the thermo Fisher
ion pgms or s5 platforms for data
analysis we have a couple of different
options depending on whether or not you
can upload your raw sequencing data at
the client's cloud or you need to go
through and analyze this within your
particular firewalls or in your
particular institution for our basic
analysis we have this all included up in
the cloud where you could take your bra
fast queue files or underline BAM files
upload it to the cottage and data
analysis cloud and this will go through
and take the raw sequencing file do all
the primer trimming do all the read
mapping and come out with an excel file
that gives you the number of molecular
tags per individual gene from there you
can take the molecular tag data upload
it into a secondary analysis site and
this will allow you to go through and
calculate your full change values and
then from there we typically go through
and push this into the ingenuity
platform which allows us to go through
and to calculate out the and do the
pathway mapping that we might be
interested in looking at if this is not
an option to upload the human data that
you may be working on to cryogens cloud
we do have plug-ins that are available
for the CLC biomedical workbench and
then we also have some other ways that
we can work with you if you'll be doing
high throughput screening to move some
of the cottage and data solutions into
your existing data analysis pipeline for
going through in designing experiments
we'd like to go through and design the
best experiment from start to finish in
order to get high quality data so
currently four species coverage for
covering human mouse and rat samples for
our gene expression platform for going
through and getting statistically
relevant for change numbers we read
to go through and to have biological
replicates for some of us that been
going to in doing whole transcriptome
sequencing we sometimes think about
going to and doing technical replicates
just to go through engage how our
library construction is going on because
we have the unique molecular indexes
here we can go through and really focus
on getting biological replicates because
with the unique molecular indexes we can
actually go back and calculate how many
times we're sequencing the same
molecules and this allows us to go
through and look at the statistics
around the technique versus going
through and looking at the statistics
and on the biology by going through and
doing at least three biological
replicates or having three patients in a
cohort this allows us to go through and
calculate out a p-value using of
students t-test and so with a full
change and a p-value we can go through
and start to look at lo changing gene
expression as a statistically relevant
event versus something that may be a
high fold gene that's only a few of our
samples for going through and looking at
SFP samples the average amplicon that
we're looking at is about 97 basis for
our gene expression portfolio with the
range being about 95 to 130 bases since
we have very small amplicons this works
great for FFPE and it means that when we
go through and do our sequencing run we
only need to do 150 basis of a single
and read this cuts down on time that you
have to use your sequencing machine as
well as reagent consumption for
designing our assays currently we're
going through and using the same guys
design criteria as we use for qpcr to
build our biological work space for
viewing our primer design we went
through and we took all the transcripts
out of the ensembl database everything
out of the ncbi refseq once database
which were about two hundred and
seventy-five thousand transcripts and we
threw them into our design engine we
went through we mapped off regions where
you have overlapping transcripts between
non-coding RNAs and mrna s and then we
went through and took a unique region
that's unique for an mRNA or a long line
coding RNA we took the most unique
region so the most common exon or most
common element that's available for that
gene region and so we're going through
and we're using a unique region for
particular gene in order to say whether
this is an mRNA or long non-coding RNA
because we've already gone through and
Deek involved the transcriptome before
we've done our primer design this means
that we can go through and we don't need
to do any sort of stranded library
preparations and makes the workflow very
straightforward for going through and
determining how deep we need to sequence
our samples if you're going through and
doing traditional sequencing and you're
doing whole transcriptome sequencing if
you're doing mRNA seek you might be
using twenty million reads if you're
going through and you're doing a whole
transcriptome sequencing you might be
using sixty to a hundred million reads
all of those are based on calculations
to go through and say whether we
sequence deep enough in order to see low
expressing transcripts with having the
unique molecular indexes if we see two
to five reads of the same unique
molecular index we believe that we'd
sequence peeping up for a lot of
researchers that are going through and
using our kids what we have are a couple
of tables as a starting guide we go
through and do the first experiment we
look at the characteristics of the
sample by looking at how many times
you're reading the same movie over and
over again in the sequencing run and
then we can go through and we can
optimize the number of samples that are
putting on to their sequencing run this
often means that researchers can go
through and add even more samples than
what you see in our table and it allows
them to have a significant cost savings
as compared to going through and doing
this by just theory for building your
libraries we don't need to do any
stranded library prep any ribosomal
depletion or any globin depletion and
the current content that we have is
about fifty five thousand targets we
have about 25,000 mRNAs as well as about
30,000 long non-coding rnas so now we
have a kind of really interesting or a
really unique concept we have the unique
molecular indexes the single primer
extension we have a really easy to lose
workflow it has all the bioinformatics
and now what we really have to worry is
about our experiments so as a biologist
we often have to go through and think
about where we're going to isolate our
material from so these kits work
extremely well on going through and
looking at pre circulating nucleic acids
so
RNA and DNA from dead cells if you're
able to go through and get those out of
the bloodstream these can cause cancer
related mutations that we can go to and
query if you're interested in looking at
micro RNA we can go through and we can
look at micro RNA that might be complex
to proteins and they actually be a very
valuable very important biomarker we can
go through and look at RNA signatures
out of exosomes these are tiny micro
vesicles that are found in body fluids
that transport RNA between cells these
exosomes can contain mRNA long
non-coding RNA micro RNA even DNA
fragments that we can go through and
sequence we can go through and enrich
for circulating tumor cells our lower
limit of detection for our gene
expression kids is currently about 10000
or 100 pica grams so if we can go
through and encapsulate ten cells and go
through an isolate ten different cells
we can go through and use a kid and in
our current configuration and therefore
tissue samples fresh samples or any sort
of FFP samples for going through and
developing the content that we put into
our comprehensive panels we have a team
of scientists at collagen these are PhD
trained scientists that go through and
look at external databases scientific
publications and the collagen knowledge
base and use ingenuity to go through and
come up with the panels that you see
here on your screen so we have these
comprehensive panels that are available
for going through and looking at
prototypical types of biology so we have
the cancer transcriptome this has 395
targets this allows you to go through
and look at all of the tumor suppressor
genes acqua genes things that can drive
oncogenesis as well as things that if
the expression level is perturbed we see
this in a lot of cancer samples we have
the information and immunity
transcriptome these have all your
cytokines chemokines your PD ones your
things that respond to PD one therapies
any sort of immune reaction to be
characterized by looking at these
particular targets we have the signal
transduction pathway finder this has
about 400 targets that allow us to go
through and look at about sixteen
canonical pathways this is the panel
that I'm using when we go through and
look at the responses to the chemicals
that we're adding to the cells and you
can read off the rest of the names of
the targets or the rest of the names of
the pathways that we have here
the genes that we put in this are
available on high-end comm you can just
go through and find the product and you
can see the genes and then we also have
a few apps on our website where you can
go through and you can type in your
favorite gene and it will map it back to
which of our comprehensive panels that
it's in all of a comprehensive panels
have already undergone a lot of
verification for their performance we
bought through and tested that all these
acids work and we can go through and
know that they have adequate sensitivity
to see down to very real copy numbers
that may be present in your samples from
the comprehensive panels we can go
through and build an extended panel so
this is one of my favorite experiments
to do I'm always looking for long
non-coding RNAs that are the next
putative biomarker so I use a Google
Scholar search I collect all the long
non-coding RNAs that come out in the
literature over a couple of months and
then I go through and I add these back
to our comprehensive cancer panel and
then I screen samples that I have in our
freezer so I can go through at the end
of these experiments and I can go
through and say well particularly on
non-coding RNAs are going to be specific
for a particular type of cancer versus
other ones that will be universal for
any cancer sample because they're in
close proximity to a tumor suppressor
gene or an aqua gene or around where a
fusion event happens and they become
active after there's some sort of
transcriptional disruption in the
example we have over a hundred and
eighty PCR panels that we've been using
in the past as a way to go through an
approaches now with sequencing we can go
through and we can take those 180 gene
expression panels and transform them
over to our client c panels we go
through and we take the 84 pathway
specific genes of interest and then we
substitute out pcr controls for Kyah
seek controls in addition we have over
500 pathway maps on chi-ching comm you
can go to the pathway maps and there is
a blue gene circle you can click on that
and then you can extract all the genes
from that pathway map dump it into our
custom builder and build yourself a
custom panel based on that particular
pathway for building custom panels this
is a very easy thing to do that you can
do all by yourself
if you go to college and Comm if you log
into the website you can go through and
you can upload your favorite gene list
you're in Samba Y
jeez your ncbi refseq Huan's ids and
once you put it in here you select your
species hit search and then what that's
going to do is it's going to map it back
to the genes that we have and find the
assays for that what to find to the
assays it'll go through and ask you to
add back some controls we have genomic
DNA controls that will go through and
look at transcriptionally dead regions
of the genome and allow us to identify
that as well as housekeeping genes that
we can use for data normalization when
you go through and you're build your
custom panels there's a couple of files
that you can download you get an excel
file and then most importantly you have
a bed file and with this bed file you
can see the actual region that we're
going through and we're querying as a
look as a gene expression assay so in my
particular experiment we're going
through and we're starting with
ourselves in a 96-well plate and this is
the work for that we do day one we see
the seeds we sell the feed that sells
out on just before we go home day two we
come in we treat the cells for about an
hour with our drug compounds or even
less then we go through and we extract
the RNA using a kiyah cube 96 HT you put
the plate in here walk away from this
from here would go through and then we
check the RNA to the RNA quality by
looking at it on a spectrophotometer and
then we go through and we check the RNA
quality by going through and running it
through an instrument we call the Chi XL
it gives us ribosomal integrity and goes
through and calculates and gives us a
Rin number this allows us to do this
while probably I about half way through
today so by the time we come back from
lunch we already know whether or not the
RNA is good enough quality to move
forward or whether or not we killed
themselves in the drugs because we see
that there's a fragmentation of the RNA
from here we go through and we complete
the library construction and then we can
QC it by using a cyber green Mason
method and going through and doing a
final QC on the library with the same
kxl that we use for our RNA analysis so
in a library construction we're going
through once we have the RNA that passes
QC we go through and we build our
libraries in 96 well plates and once we
have libraries constructed we're going
through and putting this on
to a illuminant next week 500 using 151
based single and reads and we're using
the mid capacity trip so about 130
million reads to go through and look at
96 samples we start day 3 at home we go
through and we take our raw size key
file we upload it to the kaijin cloud
while we upload it to the cottage and
cloud it's going to go through and do
the read mapping primer trimming and
give us the unique molecular indexes
this takes about an hour to parse
through about 96 samples the total time
it takes is really dependent on the
number of targets and how complex the
the sequencing file is but usually
within an hour we've now gone from raw
sequencing down to an excel file that
has unique molecular indexes in that
excel file this is actually looking at
the sequencing run that I did for this
particular application we have the
samples across the top here we have the
total reads that we have per sample we
break it down into reads that get
dropped for various regions we expect
the feed less than 5% of the reads get
dropped because of technical reasons so
primer dimer off target amplification or
things that don't map then we get down
to the total number of reads that we use
for molecular barcodes counting the
number of molecular tags and the reads
per molecular tag mean all this
information is something that we can use
to go through and make our next
sequencing run better and it could tell
us about whether we're under sequencing
over sequencing and give us a guide to
having a very good sequencing experiment
from there there's another tab that
spits off the raw molecular tags and now
we can treat these raw molecular tags
just like we do with traditional PCR
data we need to go through and normalize
to either internal housekeeping genes or
normalized to the total molecular tag
count when you go through and use our
secondary data analysis site for taking
the molecular tax the full change values
it will give you recommendations of the
best method to use we use the gene norm
algorithm in there to go through and
predict out stable housekeeping genes so
you can take the most stable ones across
all the experimental data you're looking
at and it will also go through and
recommend whether or not we can do a
global normalization so going through
and looking at the
and looking at some of the features that
we have available in our secondary
analysis light we have ways to go
through and make scatter plots volcano
plots as well as to do cluster grams and
this is an example of one of my data
sets and I'm looking at here I have the
genes that are upregulated the genes are
down regulated and on the right hand
side I have a cluster gram and if you
could actually go through and see this
cluster gram on the long axis here I
have 421 targets which are my sixteen
canonical signaling pathways across the
top here I have my samples that are
clustering from here what this
clustering is tying us is that the gene
expression is being the gene expression
for each individual sample so and then
the gene expression whether the
similarities of these are the same
across different samples and when we run
these experiments we always add back
known inhibitors that have a known
biological function and we can go
through and look at the grouping of
samples as a function of the gene
expression grouping and understand
whether there are similar pathways or
similar patterns that let our unknown
drugs map back and be very similar to
our known treatments that we're doing
and once we have this all of this data
we take this and now we put this into
ingenuity and this allows us to go
through and start to use that data
overlay pathway Maps on top of this and
also do predictions so in this
particular study here we're looking at
HTF inhibitors then blue and in orange
our genes that are up and down regulated
and then in white our biological
predictions that's coming out of this
data set these biological predictions
come from us asking what genes may be in
between known interactors or by going
through and asking what our downstream
transcriptional activators that might be
the start of our next experiment you can
run a large number of samples depending
on the situated the nice thing about
targeted sequencing is if this can be
very very cost effective depending on
whether you have a my C can next week or
an ion PGM or f5 depending on the panel
state the number of genes in your panel
as well as the number of reads you want
to use per individual gene you can go
through and if you have 15 million reads
you can
30-100 gene panels if you're going
through and using an ion s5 and you're
using the 60 to 80 million read chips
you can run over a hundred samples at
one time so you can now start to go
through and look at a lot of genes and a
lot of samples and biology no longer is
limited by a 96 or 384-well PCR play
it's no longer sample limited and you
can start to go through and you can
really start to do a lot of biology
if we compare going through and doing
targeted sequencing versus qPCR the
material that we started with is one
pull of primers everything is a single
pool reaction it's very amendable to
putting it into either script tubes or
96-well plates from building the library
versus 105 384 well plates for one time
we spent 14 hours on an x league run we
loaded up the instrument went home came
back the next day and got all of our
data crunched versus 310 hours of going
through and running this on a PC our
instrument hands-on time it took us
about three hours to do that versus 105
hours on a pcr instrument and most
importantly we started with 10 nanograms
and sample versus 4,000 anagrams to do
the same thing with pcr this small
amount of sample is allowing us to even
move from 96-well plates down into
smaller well plates it allows us to have
a high concentration of the unique
compounds that we're developing and from
the same RNA we can go back and do micro
RNA profiling as well as look for other
RNA signatures so I tell you how I
showed you how to play to apply that
Lumias and SPE to gene expression but we
can also do the same thing for going
through and looking at DNA variants with
DNA variants we can now go through and
use the power of the unique molecular
index needs as well as the single primer
extension to go through and to do error
correction and remove any sort of PCR
sequencing errors versus going through
and actually being able to call a true
low frequency mutation so in this
particular example here we have EGFR
exon 21 we go 3 and we have 5 reads for
this region and we see one variant in
one of our five reads and we can't
actually go through and tell whether or
not the
is a PCR sequencing error or a true
low-frequency variation however if we go
through and we start to analyze the
unique molecular indexes that we've
incorporated before we go through and do
any amplification of the system this
allows us to go through and identify on
the left-hand side everything has the
same unique molecular index and we have
one variant in there this is most likely
a false negative versus on the right
hand side where we have two unique
molecular index and we see the same
variant for everything to go through and
do this we've come up with a very simple
workflow it's about a nine hour workflow
with most of this as hands-off time we
start by going through and starting with
the DNA either genomic DNA or SSP DNA we
go through and we do an enzymatic
fragmentation this is not the same as
using a tag mentation we have a very
unbiased way of going through and using
an enzymatic fragmentation that allows
us to control for the size as well as
being a very nice random fragmentation
that leads to a very high complex
library we go through and we do a
library construction by first ligating
on the adapters which contain the unique
molecular indexes and then all of our
subsequent downstream reactions look
very similar we do a single primer
extension followed by a PCR
amplification we go through and we can
do inline sample indexing and then we
have a library that's ready to throw on
to your sequencing instrument for going
through them looking at fusion genes
this is a very important field in a lot
of cancer biology and we can go through
and apply the unique molecular indexes
and the single primer extension to
pretty much go through and either use
this as a validation technique where we
know both of the partners or to go
through and to use this more discovery
biology so what you're looking at here
is a graphical representation of some
samples that we've been looking at we're
looking at the 6 kb 1 and the VMP 1
fusion genes and the top here versus the
AR fgf2 and as i left two ones in the
bottom here and the way that we're
showing this graphical representation is
we went through we constructed our
libraries did the sequencing and now
we're mapping back not only
fusion genes but we're also going back
and looking at transcript variability
within the samples the little numbers
that if you increase the size and your
screen that you see here are unique
molecular indexes so we can go through
and we can get very quantitative counts
of how often we're seeing the exons come
together and we can also go through and
identify the fusion partners here by
going through and identifying the fusion
partners with the umi's we can actually
go through and say how much this this
fusion is present within the population
that were looking at here so with this
product we call this the RNA scan
product we can go through and identify
fusion genes transcripts as well as
overlay potential hot spots or hot spot
identification and then on the data
analysis side we can go through and even
look at gene expression differences if
necessary to go through and build our
fusion gene library it's a very
straightforward procedure very similar
to doing DNA sequencing we go through
and we start with our RNA with our RNA
we're going to go through and we're
going to make double-stranded cDNA and
then their library construction is
exactly the same we go through and we
added the adapters go through and do a
single primer extension and then do go
through and complete out the library so
with this I'd like to go through and
kind of summarize what we talked about
today biomarkers come in a lot of
different flavors you have gene
expression micro RNA expression profiles
fusion genes you can look at copy number
variants DNA variants as well as
insertion and deletions and what I
showed you here is that all of this is
possible to do with NGS and you don't
need to go through and have a very
expensive or high capacity NGS
instrument but if you go through and use
targeted sequencing and for targeted
sequencing we're talking about thousands
of targets in the library or we're
talking about hundreds of genes for DNA
variant analysis and while going through
and looking at all the fusion partners
that you may be interested in we can go
through and actually just plug and play
in these different types of panels into
your research workflow so as long as you
can go through and you can have samples
that to look at you can go through and
decide what you want to look at DNA very
RNA panels for looking at gene
expression confusing gene or looking at
the entire mir know you do your NGS run
and then tron the back end of this we
have a very simplified data analysis
pipeline well we can go through take the
fast key files use the molecular indexes
as a way to go through and improve the
data analysis and then go through and
have interpretation so with that I'm
going to close out today's seminar and
take some questions that we have here
and again I'd like to thank everybody
for coming to a kind of high overview of
targeted sequencing at catagen
when you think about college and
sequencing think about the unique
molecular bar tears as well as the
single primer extension which gives us
really high quality targeted sequencing
on almost any sample typing they're
looking at thank you well thank you so
very much doctor for your presentation
and thank you for the audience here as
well we already have some questions here
or two queued up and before we get
started on the question and answer
section I would like to remind our
audience as well how to submit those
questions you can submit questions by
typing them and the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window again we're going to
try to answer as many of those questions
as possible and dr. we do have our first
question here and it's in the size
selection validation in the quality
control otherwise how is this controlled
or evaluated so both of our size
selection is controlled by the beads
that we use to clean up in the buffer
conditions that we're using there
they're used to enrich for a certain
size of the DNA that comes out of or the
double-stranded DNA that comes out of
each of the steps so the size selection
is really a function of how we've gone
through and the buffering conditions of
the magnetized beads that were using and
clinking and how big are they you me and
are you sure that similar sequences are
not there in the human genome so there
you have the unique molecular indexes
that we're currently using everything is
based on 12 bases so we have 12 random
bases that are being incorporated into
our library construction we're pretty
sure that with the roomies in addition
to the
sequencing characteristics that you're
looking at that you're not going to have
these UMI's being miscounted throughout
the entire genome so we know that the
characteristics of the primer net we're
working on and as we go and do the data
analysis we can see that they're in our
data analysis pipeline we're actually
able to map where the UMI's are where
the primer is based on this being a
targeted sequencing approach so we don't
have any problem with the emmys being
populated throughout the genome or
miscounting and what is the length of
the intercoms most of the length of the
the amplicons that we're using for gene
expression are about 97 bases and then
for the DNA and fusion genes we're going
through and using very small amplicons
as well so for DNA were typically
capturing anywhere from 80 up to about
150 bases and then for the fusion genes
it's about the same thing around 82 to
larger sizes for the sequencing
characteristics on the gene expression
profiles we use 150 base single n reads
which captures the gene information that
allows us to map it back for the target
DNA panels that we use we use 150 base
paired end reads which allows us to
capture all the information and then for
the fusion genes we use asymmetric
sequencing we take 150 bases from the
known side and then 250 bases from the
unknown side and this allows us to go
through and to identify both fusion
partners or the other partner to the
assay that we're looking at thank you
and our next question is is how long
does it take to make a custom panel
those custom panels we can make within
three weeks so we have a large inventory
of out they sitting in the freezer we
have a large selection of panels already
available on the website so what we're
doing here is with the custom panels is
often we're just going through and
taking inventory that we already have in
the freezer assembling the panels and
putting them together to go as we have
more and more orders that come in we
inventory more and more genes and at
some point we'll have most of the human
assays all inventory which will cut our
three weeks down
- even less than two weeks thank you and
do the duties work on bacteria and fungi
currently we're only supporting a human
mouse and rat for our gene expression
port portfolio as well as only human for
our fusion genes and target DNA
sequencing thank you and can we protect
a fusion gene RNA expression analysis
and mutation detection from the same
sample that's a great question
we can go through and we can as long as
isolate DNA and RNA we can go through
and identify these so at hydrogen we use
what's called the all prep kit we start
with our sample we isolate the DNA it
goes towards the DNA workflow and then
from the RNA this ends up isolating all
the RNA from 18 bases and up so we can
use a mere no to go through and look at
the near known profile do a gene
expression as well as identify fusion
genes and what is the minimum amount of
RNA required for fusion gene analysis
currently our recommendation for fusion
gene analysis is based on about starting
with about 15 min agreeance of total on
enriched RNA this is based on a fusion
gene being within your sampling space so
again it comes back to how frequent
you're going to have the fusion gene and
the sample that you're working at but a
good guide is to go through and to work
with about 15 minutes thank you and here
our final question on for today that we
have time for is the QA a seeks
compatible for single cell works yeah
this is a great question I'm currently
we can get down to about 10 nanograms
our excuse me 10 cells or 100 pika grams
for gene expression profile for single
cell works we're developing out a
different protocol to get us down to a
single cell to incorporate into amis
along with the the current work form
that we have so I would recommend for
the lower limit 10 cells or 100 pika
grams for gene expression and thank you
and dr. Dave any final comments today
again I'd like to thank everyone for
attending here and being patient without
that book
that's it and put pagoda calm calm and
to click on around there and you can
find where we have all the documentation
there as well as how to get in touch
with us and to actually think about
going through and evaluating whether
this will work for their research
alright thank you so very much
I'd also like to thank dr. once again
for his outstanding presentation I'd
like to thank our sponsor kaijin for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January of 2017 you'll receive an email
from Lavin's alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye